We talked, let me talk to
him Monday about Frost's, uh,
idea of the sound of sense.
Uh, and uh, vernacular, uh,
speech forms, uh, his,
his wish to put these
intention or as he put it,
strained relations, uh,
with metrical pattern.
Uh,
the primary metrical pattern in frost
a is the primary metrical pattern in
English poetry, which is
to say blank verse, uh,
or unrivaled I abic pentameter.
Well,
a meter, what is meter a meter is, uh,
it's a scheme for organizing
verse four, organizing, um,
lines of verse. Uh,
it's a scheme that, uh,
in English counts,
accents or stresses per line,
uh, and then arranges
them in a pattern. Um,
ordinarily in accentual syllabic verse,
which is what we're reading,
uh,
more often than not in English poetry,
the accents are arranged in
relation to unaccented syllables,
creating a kind of limited array of,
of standard units.
Uh,
the most standard of these as the I am
the I am is,
is a simple pattern of an unstressed
syllable followed by a stressed one,
a boat about,
uh,
address a coat.
These are all simple.
I am Vick phrases that you hear
in our language all the time.
If you,
if you repeat a boat three times a boat,
a boat, a boat, you have trinity.
I am Vic [inaudible] a
three. I am in a row. Uh,
if you do it four times, you've
got a Ted transmitter, uh,
uh, more common meter, uh, in English.
And if you repeat them five times,
you have pentameter,
uh, accent. Uh, what is an accent? Um,
for some of you, this will seem
self evident. For others, uh,
it'll seem like a great puzzle. Um,
uh, what constitutes an accident?
When you, what, what, what, what, uh,
what does an accent in
a given English word?
In fact,
uh,
linguists often argue about
this subject and it's a,
it's a complicated, uh, one, um,
accent is something somewhat difficult
to define and categorize. Uh,
don't worry about. Uh,
poetry is not interested in,
in, uh, expert debate,
uh, at all. Uh, and it,
it converts the, the, you know,
big spectrum of possible
degrees of accent, uh,
into those two simple categories,
stressed and unstressed syllables.
Uh,
so,
uh,
if you're unsure about the medical
definition of a line because it's hard to
discriminate between levels of stress
as will almost certainly be the case,
remember that, uh, more
often than not, uh,
the context takes over,
uh,
and the regular beat of a meter
rules and perhaps promotes an accent,
uh, in, uh,
a phrase that might not otherwise
seem to have one to you.
Let's, uh, illustrate these,
these general points by uh, uh,
just reading together and trying to hear
the beginning of a Robert Frost poem
birches on, on page two
11. And the, the Norton,
this is an example
of blank verse and that is,
uh,
always to be blank for us always
perhaps confusingly to be district a
distinguished from free verse blank
verse is unrivaled I amic Pentameter free
verse is non metrical poetry.
Another thing all together.
This is blank verse. It's the language of
Shakespeare. It's a language of Milton.
When I see birches Ben to left and right
across the lines of straight or dark or
trees,
I like to think some boys
been swinging them well.
Um,
for me when I try to make sense
of the meter of given lines,
uh,
I think it's useful to try to settle,
to start those syllables that
seem most clearly stressed,
uh, to, you know, identify where there,
there isn't a question, uh, and uh,
use that then as a structure from which
to interpret the rest of the lines.
So why don't we do that together?
Uh, just looking at this first,
first line when I see birches Ben to
left and right when I see birches Ben to
left and right
when I see birches bend
to the left and right,
and sometimes it's not good
to repeat it too often,
then you start to become unhinged.
Uh, let, let, let's, uh, let's,
let's see if we can't identify
those syllables that well,
we all are going to agree
on, uh, we're, we're,
where's the first accident that you
really want to say? That's an accent.
I
birches
bend.
Okay.
Speak Up. What's left, right
debate there.
Uh,
everybody, when I
propose, uh, another, uh,
another stress in that line,
yes.
Uh, there's a stress on when and see,
hmm, okay. Well, what if I had the phrase,
I see what, uh, what would
be stressed in that phrase?
I see.
Si
that's true. Um, when I see
birches Ben to left and right,
I think I would want to scan
that, that, uh, line, uh, as,
as a bit of an odd beginning, uh, I
think that word see is, deserves the,
the, uh, the accent there.
Uh, and so it's, um, the,
the first first unit of the
sound isn't quite normative.
Uh,
it takes frost a little sweep to get
going when I see birches Ben to left and
right. But by the time we
finished the end of that line,
we are really right in the middle
of very regular I ambit pentameter.
When I see birches Ben to left and
right across the lines of straighter,
darker trees.
I like to think some boys been swinging
them across the line of straight,
darker trees. Let's, let's do the
lines of straight or darker trees.
Let's do that line. Uh, accents here.
Cross lines.
Straight
trees. Yeah. I, that one's pretty simple.
Uh, thank you for us. You, you, you have,
you know, delivered, uh, this,
this, this, uh, to us. Uh,
and as is not often the case, uh, every,
excuse me as is not
seldom the case in frost.
There's almost a kind of metaphorical
play between what he's describing. Uh,
and uh,
the sounds with which he is doing
the describing here, the uh,
uh, this image of, of uh,
aligns of trees and the uh,
metrical regularity of that, um,
uh, verse that describes them.
I like to think some
boys been swinging them.
Yeah.
What about this line?
Yeah,
I like to think some
boys been swinging them.
That word
swinging gives a nice swing to the,
it's into the I am.
Anyone said Amen.
Uh,
the,
the point is that a swing has
some interesting swinging effect.
Um, yeah. I'm not sure how to
describe that exactly. Um, uh,
yeah, we want, we want to put a stress on
swing. Uh, what other words in that line?
I'm sorry. Think good. Like, Yup.
I like is like,
I see,
I like to think some boys swing them.
Yeah. This too is, is it utterly regular?
I am big pentameter line,
uh,
unstressed syllable followed by a
stressed syllable, five in a row,
and yet think about the qualities of
sound that are so different between,
across the lines of
straight or darker trees.
And I like to think some
boys been swinging them. Uh,
the,
what frost is interested in is
the what really ultimate, uh,
a variety of, of uh, sounds
that he is able to reduce,
uh, as that metrical pattern, uh,
comes into some kind of a tension with
a English sentence sounds as he calls.
And, uh, and uh, with the,
the effect that each of frost
lines of I am big pentameter has,
has different qualities even
when they're utterly regular. Uh,
and there are in frost often,
uh, some variations. Uh,
this is something I'd like you to
practice, uh, uh, I'd like you to,
to think about,
be conscious of and it's
something we can return to a,
it's not something I expect
you to necessarily master or,
um, uh, or, or, uh,
become advanced, uh, in,
um, uh, um, uh, you were, you were, um,
expertise.
Uh,
but it is a dimension of the poetry
that's absolutely essential to what it is
and to what your doing. When
you read a and you hear, uh,
that voice speaking.
And so I'd like you to work
on attuning yourself to it.
Uh, what can you do with
sound as interpreters?
How do we start to fund you?
Make a connection between what
we hear and what things mean?
Well, uh, in frost
case, as I'm suggesting,
there's often very skillful
in complex, uh, uh,
imitation going on between for us sounds.
Uh,
and what he's imaging or describing are
the actions and events and a palm that's
the case, a marvelously in this poem. Um,
uh, and it, and I'd be
happy to talk about, uh, um,
particular examples with, with any of
you who'd like to work through it. Um,
but,
uh,
the point I want to make about it is as
much more general and we don't have to
look at, uh, a particular
cases to make it a,
this is a poem about bending
and breaking or not breaking,
uh, forms, uh,
forms the material,
givens of the world. Uh,
it's a poem in fact about
strained relation, uh,
uh, in, in a kind of
play, uh, that, uh, frost,
uh, is, is exploring, uh, and
that strange relation that he's a,
that the boy, uh, achieves
as he learns how to play, uh,
with these trees. Well, uh,
that's a version of what we hear in the
poem when we hear the forms of strange
relation between, um, uh,
frost dynamic speech sounds and the
metrical pattern of his writing.
Uh, the kinetic activity of the
form of the poem in other words,
uh, is something that's like,
but it's also itself for Frost,
an instance of the relations
of force and counter force,
desire and gravity,
uh,
that the poem is describing the
meter has, in other words, uh,
in relation to his individual
sentence sounds, uh,
some of the flexibility and
also resistance that those
trees have in relation to
the boy, uh, using them
to swing, to swing,
to go up and down,
to come and go safely.
Uh,
these are primal forms of
play. Uh, if you, if you like,
uh,
that suggest forms of poetic activity.
Also spiritual activity, uh, frosts,
ways of using language in short,
our, our, like our, our versions of,
uh, the boys' way of
using the trees. Let's,
let's look at the poem together.
I'll read it.
I like to think some boys been swinging
them but swinging doesn't bend them down
to stay as ice storms do.
Frost is going to counter
pose the boys swinging to uh,
the natural forces, uh,
imaged in the ice storm.
Often.
You must have seen them loaded with Isis.
Sunny winter morning after a rain,
they'd click upon themselves as the
breeze rises and turn many colors as the
stor cracks and crazes there a namel
soon the sun's warmth makes them shed
crystal shells shattering and
avalanching on the snow crest,
such heaps of broken glass to sweep away.
You'd think the inner
dome of Heaven had fallen.
They are dragged to the withered brack
and by the load and they seem not to
break the ones they are
bowed so low for long,
they never write themselves.
You may see their trunks arching
in the woods years afterwards,
trailing their leaves on the ground
like girls on hands and knees that throw
their hair before them,
over their heads to dry in the sun.
But I was going to say when truth broke
in with all her matter of fact about the
ice storm,
I should prefer to have some boy bend
them as he went out and in to fetch the
cows.
Some boy too far from town to learn
baseball who's only play was what he found
himself summer or winter
and could play alone
one by one.
He subdued his father's trees by writing
them down over and over again until he
took the stiffness out of them
and not one but hung limp.
Not One was left for him to conquer.
He learned all there was to learn about
not launching out too soon and so not
carrying the tree away
clear to the ground.
He always kept his poise
to the top branches,
climbing carefully with the same pains
you use to fill a cup up to the brim and
even above the brim.
Then he flung out where it feet first
with a swish kicking his way down through
the air to the ground.
So as I once myself a swinger of Birches,
and so I dream of going back to be,
it's when I'm weary of considerations in
life is too much like a pathless would
wear. Your face burns and tickles
with the cobwebs broken across it.
And one eye is weeping from a
twigs having lashed across it open.
I'd like to get away from Earth a while
and then come back to it and begin over.
May know fate willfully misunderstand me
and half grant what I wish and snatched
me away and not to return earth,
the right place for love.
I don't know where it's
likely to go better.
I'd like to go by climbing a birch tree
and climb black branches up a snow white
trunk toward heaven until
the tree could bear no more,
but dipped it's top and set me down again.
That would be good.
Both going and coming back.
One could do worse than
be a swinger of birches.
So think about the birches as a tool,
another tool.
But this time of tool for play,
uh,
a tool for playing alone as in mowing
a frost is writing about solitude
in essential loneliness.
The boys solitude is like the mowers.
Who's absent?
Well, other children. Uh,
the other character that's mentioned
in the poem is the boy's father who's
trees.
They are the property
owner who also is absent.
It's his absence that leaves the
boy alone to his own devices. Uh,
we might think of him not
simply as, uh, the, the, uh,
farm or who holds the
deed to those Birch's,
but as maybe God the
father who created them,
uh,
and is likewise absent or invisible
in the solitude, the
solitude, uh, that absence.
Um,
the boy uses the tree to work
his will playfully this time.
He's not really a worker, uh,
to work his will on the world.
And the boy uses the trees
to do two things, right,
to go up or go out and come back
to return. Uh, this activity in,
in a wonderful homely way is
a version of romance quest.
It's an image of a cent toward heaven,
uh, from which, uh, the boy returns. Uh,
he's able to rise to,
to transcend the limits of
his own body and station. Uh,
at the same time,
it's dangerous.
It's dangerous to want to
get away from Earth Awhile,
uh, to get your feet
entirely off the ground. Uh,
what might happen to
you? Uh, uh, well, uh,
to put too much pressure on any
tool is to risk breaking it,
uh,
breaking down,
maybe a crashing,
coming back to earth like ICARUS.
Uh, the, uh, overreach here,
the poet after, uh, is,
is subject to gravity in frost to the
force of the earth that checks it's a
counterweight to frost,
romantic longing,
the skill and the play that for us just
talking about a depends on being able to
use a tool,
in this case,
the tree emblematic of the world in its
sturdy but also delicate materiality to
use the tool to return
safely to the ground,
to get your feet back on the ground for
earth's the right place for love for us
as,
uh,
it's love that makes the boy
climb as it made the mower work.
Remember, but who was
talking about love? It's a,
uh, frost is so fly. Uh, he, he,
he brings it up as if we know that this
is what he's been talking about all the
time. Uh, uh, notice in
fact, the cleverness of,
of all this discourse in the poem,
notice the freedom that he exercises,
uh, in unfolding what feels like
an improvisitory monologue, uh,
in which he makes you race to
keep up with him, uh, as he, uh,
follows as semi hidden logic
that he treats as self evident.
Uh,
notice that final colloquial phrase to go.
He repeats it twice.
I don't know where it's
love is likely to go better.
And then I'd like to
go by climbing a tree,
a wonderful phrase to go,
uh,
meaning want a variety of things, uh, uh,
to go in the sense of, uh, uh, to
make, uh, to make something work out,
to make it go, uh, to journey,
to choose how to live,
uh,
to go to the limit, uh, where
the tool can bear no more.
Uh, yeah. And, and, and people use
that phrase to mean to die, don't they?
Uh, you know, we've talked about,
I'd like to go in this way.
All those resonances in those two words.
Uh,
on Monday I stressed that
poetry was for frost,
always a mode of work.
Uh,
and that work was for him a model
of poetic activity with mowing.
Uh,
as the example I said that in frost
meaning is always something made.
Uh,
something that works on and works for
frosts,
modernity,
consistent that the idea that a truth
is something that's concrete and
contingent, uh, not a
metaphysical matter, uh,
not an ideal principle.
And then it's something that's only
available in the act of deriving it,
constructing it. A, an
act that is ordinary,
that's in completable,
uh,
and therefore necessarily
always, uh, to be, uh,
repeated, uh, an ongoing task.
It's something you have to
get up and do every day. Uh,
frost is a, is a kind of
materialist, uh, by which I mean,
he calls attention to the
circumstances of imagination.
It's limits and conditions.
Uh,
poetry is in frost,
uh,
an encounter between fact and desire.
What we want.
And what is,
uh,
tools in frost,
are an image of the enabling
and defining conditions,
uh, of imagination. And they include
in the, the work of poetry, uh, itself,
um, uh, all sorts of tools. Uh, all the,
um, uh, technology of language, uh,
and the technology in particular
of verse, uh, including, uh,
importantly meter, uh,
the relation between the,
the speech sounds and the metrical
frame of a poem, uh, such as birches.
Uh, it's like the relation, as I'm saying,
between the boy and the
Birches, uh, in other words,
meter is something for us,
knows how to use. It's a,
it's a material force that his
rhetoric challenges and relies on a,
gives him a means of
getting off the ground, uh,
and a means of always
getting back to it too. Uh,
and that's another kind
of doubleness and frost.
I talked about doubleness
last time. Uh, um,
think in, in birches of, of
really the extraordinary, uh,
play of, of, of language, uh,
the freedom of association,
the metaphorical invention,
uh,
all of which is being played off of the
strict demands of the meter at every
moment. It's part of the energy
and force of the poem. Uh,
the,
the work of poetry in frost that
the really the high drama of,
uh, the wheel at work in the world. Uh,
it's something that we can
actually hear in his poetry,
in the expertly explored tensions between
speech and meter in that meter too.
We're hearing,
we're hearing some of frost modernity.
Uh,
let me say more about what I mean.
Uh, let me say more about what
I mean by approaching, uh,
the question of his modernness
as modernity. Uh, uh,
from the point of view of his subjects.
Last time I showed you the, uh,
his second book and it's, it's
a, it's covering north of Boston.
Uh,
the title of that book published in 1914
and the one that more than any other,
uh,
made him famous,
locates his subjects in
a specific geography.
Uh, it's important for thinking about
frost place in modern poetry. Uh,
Boston,
well,
it was the capital of 19th century
American literature and culture, uh,
a named synonymous eventually
with gentility, uh,
puritanism, uh, uh, old
American money and style.
Uh, exactly. Uh, in other words,
everything modernism
was attacking. So, uh,
where do you go to write modern
poetry? Well, anywhere but, but Boston,
uh, pound, uh, and Elliot, uh,
importantly go to London,
Paris.
There's the New York of crane,
uh,
of Moore Stephens too,
but frost says differently.
Uh,
he alone moves poetry north of Boston.
Uh, to do this is to, uh, reverse the,
the social direction,
which everyone else is going to reverse
the direction of American modernization,
which is evacuating rural
New England, uh, uh,
sending its workers to the
cities, uh, uh, in the, uh,
new industrial economy. If you
can think about cranes, images of,
of the Brooklyn Bridge in this
course, and then compare frosts, uh,
image of the woodpile that abandoned
woodpile that some worker has left,
uh, in the, the poem
called the woodpile. Uh,
these are in a sense
complimentary images of, uh,
the modern in a America,
uh,
frost when he goes north of Boston,
uh, goes back to the country,
goes in a sense the opposite
direction, uh, that,
uh, America is going, he goes in a sense,
in an anti modern direction.
Uh, maybe even in some sense,
in a reactionary,
a direction,
at least in relation to other poets,
ideas of progress and innovation,
this move roots Frost's poetry of
work in the lives of rural workers.
Uh, people who have to sustain
and entertain themselves, uh,
uh, often on their own or alone. Uh,
what these people have to work with are,
are the tools that have been passed
down to them or sometimes that they have
invented. Uh, the, the, uh,
the poverty of the people for
us writes about is important.
It makes them materialists
two or realists like frost.
Uh, they are, uh,
acutely conscious of the circumstances
in which they live their lives,
uh, and they suffer, uh,
they rage. Uh, they're,
they're new England.
Uh,
importantly is not an
ideal pastoral place.
The heart of north of Boston is a series
of dramatic monologues and dialogues,
uh, speeches in conversations for
people who really had never spoken,
were never spoken very much in modern,
excuse me,
in American poetry before. And, uh,
who in frost speak in a
holy, distinctive way, uh,
that is in Frost's combination
of colloquial sentence,
sound and unrivaled. I ambig
pentameter a blank. First,
it is the heroic language of Shakespeare,
Milton of Wordsworth.
Uh, the death of the hired man
home burial servant to servants.
The fear. These are, these
are, are our are, uh,
poems in which a frost is, uh,
giving, um, New England workers.
The, the, the language, uh,
of the great English poets.
Uh, I've been stressing
for us solitude, well, uh,
all the, uh, uh, people frost writes
about are in some sense alone, uh,
often alone together.
Uh, they share solitude,
uh, uh, solitary to in their
relation to each other.
Uh, frost. Uh,
as a narrator in these great poems
I'm describing a frames his peoples,
uh,
words minimally with few bits
of narrative information.
He just, uh, through plunges you
into their speech, into their lives.
And, uh, you have to, you have
to in a sense work to, uh,
uh, get into their character to
be able to keep track of who is,
uh, speaking. Let's, um, look at, uh,
w what is for me the most
gripping, uh, example,
uh, in this, of this kind of poem,
home burial on page two oh four,
um,
giving us a little introduction,
a little framing, uh, and no
consoling closure really, uh,
where the moral might come in another pot.
Uh,
frost creates a kind of uncomfortable
intimacy for us with his character's,
uh, were, were, were, were,
were challenged by them, were
brought up close to them.
Uh, look at, uh, home burial here.
He saw her from the bottom of
the stairs before she saw him.
And,
and that's a kind of emblematic moment
in frost where one person is in a sense
seeing another without being seen.
She was staring down,
looking back over her
shoulder at some fear.
She took a doubtful step and then undid
it to raise herself and look again.
He spoke, advancing toward her.
What is it you see from up there?
Always for,
I want to know
this is, this is another important
frost in motivation for, I want to know,
uh, here a desire expressed between
two people, a husband and a wife.
She turned and sank upon our skirts
at that as if collapsing and her face
changed from terrified to dull.
He said to gain time. And isn't that
an interesting phrase to gain time?
What is it you see
mounting until she coward under him
for he is fearful or fearsome?
I will find out now.
You must tell me dear.
She in her place refused him any help
with the least stiffening of her neck and
silence.
She let him look sure that he wouldn't
see blind creature in a while.
He didn't see, but at
last team murmured. Oh,
and again. Oh, what is it?
What she said,
just that I see
you don't, she challenged.
Tell me what it is.
Put it into words. What does he see? Well,
the wonder is I didn't see it once and
that is the grave that he has made for
their child.
Uh,
in those blocks of speech, there's,
there's, uh, importantly there. There's,
there's white space around what they
have to say. It's almost a way of, uh,
inviting us to visualize the separation
of these two people as they speak.
And as we read,
we have to fill in the
nature of their relationship.
Uh, here, well,
people are locked into themselves in
frost and in their points of view.
Um, here, the issue in this palm is grief.
How the mother and father each
express how they deal with, uh,
the death of their child,
uh,
simply where and how they stand
in relation to each other.
They speak is important.
The woman,
the mother wishes to,
can't help herself from trying to hold
onto the dead child and she's caught
looking behind her, uh, as
if towards the past. Um,
which is also frankly a wish
to escape her husband, uh,
who is a frightening for
us to escape his will.
I think, uh, his will, his force,
these are his ways,
his resources for responding to death.
Uh,
uh, the woman's, uh,
objection as the poem and,
uh,
is summed up by his choice,
the father's choice to
bury the child himself. Uh,
he responds to this grievous loss
privately by taking it on himself,
by seeking to master it himself.
And specifically as a
worker in the grim tool,
if you like a of his,
uh, morning, uh, his,
his spade, uh, his, um,
uh, his, uh, the shovel he uses to do,
uh, the, the uh, uh, burying on,
on page two oh six,
um, she says, uh, um,
uh, well, there you go.
Sneering now, uh, and he says,
I'm not, I'm not, you make me
angry. I'll come down to you. God,
what a woman.
And it's come to this,
a man can't speak of his own child.
That's dead.
You can't speak because you don't
know how to speak. She says,
if you had feelings, you, that Doug
with your own hand, how could you,
his little grave,
I saw you from their very window.
They're making the gravel leap
and leap in air leap up like that,
like that and land so lightly
enroll back down the amount,
the mound beside the hole.
I thought, who is that man?
I didn't know you.
Well,
the father in home burial is a,
is a worker,
a worker there in those lines are
reduced to this tool that he's using,
uh, almost, uh, mechanically. That
makes the, uh, uh, dirt leap, um,
uh,
kind of desperate mechanism that's
trying to take control of the world and
failing, uh, as he, uh, uh,
well she says to him in this chills her,
I can repeat the very
words you were saying.
Three foggy mornings in one rainy
day will rot the best birch fence.
A man can build,
think of it,
talk like that at such a time.
But in fact, in his own way,
he's talking about his inability to,
uh,
keep his child alive there, uh, in,
in a kind of metaphorical way. Um, uh,
speaking of his failure to
build a fence to last, uh,
in a drives his wife ultimately,
uh,
disgusted by him away,
fearing him well.
Home burial is,
is a poem about the limits of work.
Uh,
the inability of the worker
to bring a knowable world,
a safe world into being there is in frost.
Uh,
no god,
no transcendental source of
guidance or constellation.
Nothing out there in the world,
but the material conditions
of our circumstances, uh,
over and over again, and
frost poems, uh, you see,
you see speakers, you
see the poet himself, uh,
wanting to know and wanting to know
means a pressing towards some revelation
towards, uh, some, uh, um,
a sense of the meaning of things. Uh, uh,
search for some kind of a presence
behind the way things are.
Uh, that is the subject of
the great sonnet design, uh,
uh, also in a very different
mood. Uh, the poem for once,
then something, uh, it's
also the subject of, uh,
neither out far nor in
deep, uh, which, um, uh,
I asked you to read for
today and is on to 20. Um,
I won't, I won't read it since we're
running a little short of time.
Uh, the, uh, people on the
shore that frost describes,
they're looking at to see, they're
watching for something. Uh,
but is there anything to watch for?
Is there any, anything uh, coming,
uh, uh, no, it doesn't appear so, uh,
but as he asks a,
at the end,
when was that ever a bar to any watch?
They keep,
uh, in these poems, um,
well when frost does give us images of
God or some informing presence,
that presence is imagine
negatively, uh, uh,
to be, uh, uh, well, uh,
as a kind of malevolence perhaps,
uh,
to be inferred from the arbitrariness and,
and cruelness of nature's destructive
force of the conditions of life,
of the people frost is describing.
So,
uh, if in in frost, you, you
can't look to God for it,
uh, what kind of, uh,
what kind of hope can be, uh, offered?
How can you save your soul?
This is a question for
us is interested in, uh,
in his own ways. Uh, he's
interested in redemption, uh,
important word for
Stevens to, uh, conclude.
Let me look quickly with you
at at two great late poems.
Uh, one on two 22, uh, is called provide,
provide,
well,
I'll read, I'll read
this. The witch that came,
the withered hag to wash the steps with
Pale and rag was once the beauty Abishag
the picture pride of Hollywood,
too many,
far from great and good for you to doubt
the likelihood die early and avoid the
fate.
Or if predestined to die late,
make up your mind to die and state,
make the whole stock,
exchange your own if need be occupied
the throne where nobody can call you
crone.
Some have relied on what they
knew others on being simply true,
what worked for them might work for you.
No memory of having starred atones for
later disregard or keeps the end from
being hard,
better to go down dignified with boughten
friendship at your side than none at
all. Provide, provide
and in some recordings for us then
says or somebody will provide for you.
It's a, it's a very funny poem. Uh,
and you've got triplet rhymes there
to make sure you know that frost is,
is joking and it feels like light verse
but of course, what are we laughing at?
Uh, uh, public achievement,
moral stature. They're of no use.
Uh, the end is hard and it's going to
be hard no matter how you come to it.
So you better look out for number one.
This is,
this is good old fashioned
American wisdom. Uh,
what is scathing about it,
uh,
is that frost gives up all
justification for self interest. Uh,
there's no for it except
self interest itself. Uh,
and then for us as even that won't work,
uh,
the choice is a terrifying one of no
friendship and boughten friendship,
uh, which really isn't a friendship
at all. Uh, in short, uh,
the only thing to do in life is to provide
and provide is just what you cannot
ever adequately do as the
husband in home burial knows.
This is a poem written in the depth of
the depression and also at the height of
frost fame. Uh, and, uh, the, uh, you,
you could see that kind of grim refusal
to apologize for boughten friendship,
uh,
as a kind of well as a kind of apology,
a for his own popular success.
Well,
let me conclude by just
pointing to another poem. Uh,
a late poem, uh, directive,
a poem published in 1947 a,
it's on the page following,
uh, a poem published
after the Second World
War, uh, written, uh,
written about the postwar world.
Uh,
it begins by in a sense a rehearsing
or taking us back to frosts own,
um,
initial move north of Boston back out of
all this now too much for us back in a
time made simple by the loss of detail,
burn,
dissolved and broken off like graveyard,
marble sculpture in the weather.
There's a house that is no more a house,
and that is where he's going
to take us in the poem.
You can see that house, uh,
as uh, uh, in a sense, um,
a version of the home in home
burial. Uh, the, uh, the fraud,
the frost describes it here. Uh, you know,
movingly as uh,
well an image of a home that has
lost a of a home that has failed,
um, and, and yet frosts,
uh, attention is drawn,
uh, interestingly to a play house, uh,
that is part of that
household. Uh, he says, uh,
in the middle of the poem on two 25,
first,
there's the children's house of make
believe some shattered dishes underneath
the pine,
the play things in the play house of
the children week for what little things
could make them glad.
And then for the house that
is no more a house. And so on.
At the end of the poem here,
uh,
frost gives us however,
in a kind of alternative to this image
of the failure of the home and the
failure of, um, uh, the workers life, uh,
in,
um,
our own imaginative access to a spring,
a source, uh, above, um, above the house.
That was the water of the House that
nurtured it. That was, it's, uh, um,
refreshment. He says, your
destination in your destinies,
a brook that was the water of the house
cold as a spring is yet so near its
source,
too lofty and original to rage.
I have kept hidden in the instep arch
of an old cedar at the Waterside,
a broken drinking goblet,
like the grail under a spell.
So the wrong ones can't find it.
So can't get saved as saint
marks as they mustn't in there.
He sounds like a child,
doesn't he?
I stole the goblet from
the children's play house.
Here are your waters
in your watering place.
Drink and be whole again beyond confusion.
Uh, there the, the, uh, goblet, the, uh,
um, uh, the tool that frost comes to, uh,
is a, uh, it's a tool from
romance quest. It's the grail. Uh,
it's, it's, uh, the, uh, uh,
a cup of the last supper. Uh,
but what is it? It's in fact, a broken
goblet from the children's play house.
Frost returns us there too early sources
of imagination in a children's play.
Uh, and it gives us at
least imaginatively, uh,
in this shared journey with him,
uh,
access to a kind of
primal, we're freshmen, uh,
what he calls our waters and
our watering place. Uh, it's a,
it's a disillusioned and self
consciously ironic promise of salvation,
of wholeness, uh, but
it's still a promise. Uh,
and it's a promise of the
powers of imagination and
of poetry and of poetry made
out of play and a child's play.
Well, that's a good place to stop.
Uh, next week, uh, we will, um, uh,
go to work on William Butler.
Yeats.